welcome to West Wing week your official
White House guide to everything that's
happening at 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
this week President Obama found out
about the IRS scandal by reading the
newspaper press secretary Jay Carney set
a new record for saying unfettered an
attorney General Eric Holder couldn't
remember why or when he recused himself
from which investigation in which he did
nothing wrong anyway that's made 10
through May sixteenth or what's the best
font to use on your resume after holding
a secret briefing on the Benghazi
scandal with a handful of cherry-picked
reporters the administration further
underscored its historic commitment to
transparency by releasing it completely
redacted 15 page document on federal
policy for snooping on text messages the
IRS admitted it had been improperly
subjecting Tea Party groups to
politicize scrutiny and that agency
personnel are not good at math the
president called such behavior
inexcusable and decisively moved to fire
the interim director who was leaving the
agency in a couple of months anyway the
president supporters in the media were
stunned when the associated press
announced that the White House had
secretly subpoenaed months of phone
records from the news organization Jay
Carney said that the president is a firm
believer in an unfettered free press
helpfully explaining that unfettered
means really fettered sort of like the
way inflammable means really flammable
for more information on any of these
topics go to reason.com not whitehouse
gov because the president has his hands
full fighting robots
you